looking a little put out there
input interest you in a prem bd
sure and i go hold it house rules first
there will be severe penalties for any
unauthorized recording
no drugs no groping someone catch your
eye
you do not grab them you find them in
the catalog
ask for a bd and get yourself a box i
really look that green to you
like i don't know
doors open have fun input
welcome to lizzy's
[Music]
[Music]
hey
get you something
i'm looking for evelyn parker you know
she's here
who's asking name's v
she and i have a date well v it's a
pleasure
i'm mateo uh-huh so
evelyn club's big i'm gonna have to look
around
i can't do it for you it's all right
matteo i was waiting for this one
[Music]
evelyn parker
i knew it was you as soon as you walked
in
[Music]
sensan only tequila i drank
how do you know i like to know
everything about the people i work with
either that or it was just a lucky guess
mind if you talk about the job heard you
got something for me
but not here come with me
uh-huh we'll be in the lounge mateo
anyone asks
we're not here
[Music]
i just told you
[Music]
[Music]
dex had a load to say about you called
you professional
effective and trustworthy
i hope he wasn't overselling
let's talk biz i mean it's nice but i
didn't come here to get my ego stroked
no you're here to gain some knowledge
the life-changing kind
well now you got me all excited your
target i trust you know what it is
relic secure your soul trinket key tech
in the program actually
we're tangling with arasaka making this
heist one dangerous
risky [ __ ] mm-hmm arasaka's
poured billions into personality
transfer technology
but me i just want the data on this one
the chip is tucked away inside kompecki
plaza the hotel
you ever been you know
just never rolled through that
neighborhood damn shame
the fresh they serve is sinfully good
chef must have made a deal with the
devil so where's this chip hiding
exactly
in a suite on the top floor the rooms
occupied by yorinobu arasaka
yorinobu arasaka he's in town
don't you read the scream sheets the
media couldn't get enough of yori coming
to night city
it was all over the headlines anyway
he's heir apparent to the arasaka empire
saburo arasaka's only surviving sun
what so arasaka juniors planning to grab
the reigns while in night city
only a handful of people in night city
know what the arasaka's real plans are
telling me you're one of them
look if you've got any spare aces up
your sleeve now's the time to show them
now this should make your prick perk up
yori nobu recently swiped the chip from
an arasaka laboratory
he's made a deal with netwatch aims to
sell it to them
have you spotted my ace yet or do i need
to spell things out
[Music]
fine so no arasaka's security on the
device because yorinobu whisted away in
secret
now where is he hiding it likely in a
specialized container
one that mimics an organic neural
environment
on the outside it looks like an ordinary
briefcase
and the case is you'll see for yourself
soon enough
provided we're done gossiping about the
outer sockets
okay what's next now comes the best part
follow me got something for you should
help you plan
brain dance from kompecki plaza how's
the brain dance supposed to help
me facts not thrills i think bds are
only good for
fondling virtual tits jacking off too in
those boxes
it can be a very useful tool good for
analyzing details human perception even
boosted
doesn't grasp exactly what you need
so what's on the tape yorinobu suite
the glorious interior you'll need to
locate the relic yourself
hope i grabbed enough detail to make
that possible hold up
mean to say you recorded this
bd-rec implant why you object
supposed to be your no who's pat on the
tape
means you were inside you know each
other
how else could i get all this intel i
know him pretty well actually we have
an arrangement strictly business suits
us both i think
let's see this brain dance
judy will help she's a mox too
besides we go back uh years
v this is important judy's always been
there for me
always helped out i trust her but she's
a mox
not the latest member what crew trying
not it's hard to say this week
for so you'll be a good boy yeah yeah
all right all right and keep that tongue
on a leash
relax believe it or not i'm no stranger
to tact
in biz or life
uh
i'm wade
hey there you are this is v
he's here for that bd roll and v this is
judy
best brain dance editor i know enough
already
impressive looking setup need all this
to process brain dances
analyzers sensory sig amps acoustic and
emotive wave monitors
facial expression translators judy
all right all right compiled your bd yet
what do you think will it do still
pretty raw
but yeah ought to do
v needs to get deep inside that's most
important
so let's calibrate tune it to him
believe me i've dealt with worse should
see the jig jig street porn we gotta
contend with sometimes
so we drop the inside let him look
let him rummage around right how about a
v
raw brain dance ever taking a dip before
think i can handle it let's just do this
sit down settle in and we'll get you
going
gotta create your sensory profile first
okay hit me just promise me it won't
hurt
it wants not this time now sit still
look at me i'm gonna run the analysis
soft
should feel a slight tingle
okay now let's set the optics and other
sensory cigs
look smack into these two screens
pretend it's an eye exam
get a lot of requests like this all the
time
but it's usually stuff the girls scroll
at the club i take that and do some
routine porn tuning
crank up the orgasms more like cut out
all the other [ __ ]
[ __ ] business as usual for these guys
their minds won
grocery lists spouses birthdays late
bills whatever
but even then you can re-figure things
mold the emotions into something unique
unforgettable so i can't complain
one more sec need to get the pain
receptor limiters in
okay all set you need to test your
profile first
tossing in a sample vd you can use it to
get to know the editor
now let me see where could we
can't he just use my recording why are
we wasting time
so we don't risk our necks besides gonna
take a sec
got something here shouldn't be perfect
boot it up
let me give you the tailored version
first lets you get your bearings
and we'll jump into editing be diving in
three two one
plant simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in
snatch the cash get out and we sell the
pd to those psycho freaks from the
studio
got it got it and remember everything
on full blast they'll spot us extra for
a wicked adrenaline high
okay on you go
down everybody autograph i want to see
you kissing the flooring
money now or i will [ __ ] drop you i
swear to god
whoa yeah now
before i blow your [ __ ] head off
[Music]
oh deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happens
you're alive and well intense shock
i can still feel it i remember
[ __ ] that last second
could have warned me how much it hurts
to die
trust me real death hurts much much more
not so sure about that you'll be fine
got everything set up let's switch over
to editing mode
[Music]
i'll sever the link to the bd roller's
sensory array
you'll be able to look around freely
whole scene's yours
full cam control and analysis mode so
move around
zoom in and out whatever else you come
up with think of it as your own little
sandbox
so analysis mode you control playback
can even pause when you feel the need
then you use the editor console to
unpause try it
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative
you go in snatch the cash get out and we
sell the bd to those psycho fakes from
the studio
got it got it dream as hell right well
that's not all
you can speed things up or rewind
whatever you like
give it a try rewind roll it back to the
top
you can also reset the recording that'll
take you right back to the beginning
try it now for some fun
this here's why you came in the first
place in analysis mode
you get to view and even scan details of
the enviro recorded by the bd roller
focus on the heat the gun this gunk gets
from his buddy at the beginning
now scan it simple do nothing odd don't
get creative
you go in snatch the cash get out and we
sell the bd to those psycho breaks from
the studio
got it got it and remember everything on
full blast they'll spot us extra for a
wicked adrenaline high
okay on you go
okay right here
excellent let's move on
now heads up in analysis mode you can
ferret out background noise and
conversations if the roller got close
enough this tech records
everything every little detail even the
sights and sounds the roller was never
aware of
to see the sources of the recorded
sensory signals switch to the audio
layer in the editor
go ahead and try that now
okay good now you should see several
sound signatures in the store
choose one and hone in on it
everybody so any thoughts unbelievable
seriously like what's happening right
next to me
yeah it's how bd recording implants work
they pick up
everything all the elements in the
background then an editor tweaks them
makes them pop
keep playing with the sound explore it a
bit we'll move on when you get bored
sometimes you can analyze extra layers
in the raw stuff the rollers cyberware
picked up
like what eb's got kiroshi optics that
grab infrared
meaning you should be able to grab heat
signatures from her recording
hello nice now let's wait till the guy
punches out the gunk at the counter
scanning works on peeps too walk up to
the wounded chick
try scanning her all right next thing
scroll forward to the part where our
artist gets a lead injection
now where i will [ __ ] drop you i
swear to god
whoa yeah now
before i pull your [ __ ] head off
see that they shot him and he never saw
it coming
but you will here it comes my favorite
part of the game
see the blinking thing over the entrance
surveillance cam
must have caught our shooter you'll see
in a sec
cam feeds to the screen behind the clerk
roll back to where the screens in the
kids field of vision
then scan it
his own choombasharam planned to all
along
must have got a nice slice of cred on
the black market for a bd like this
bd freaks are ready to pay a prem for a
real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit
that's like the limits of the reality
recorded by the bd roller okay
yeah it's impressive right it's too bad
most of the bds we do here are only good
for flogging the log
anyway you ready to do this look at your
wreck to know why
let's take a break still feel like that
kid when
oh yeah i think i'm done
v there's no time get it together please
okay okay go ahead
just need t-bug to link in
who running for my crew security
specialist
she'll tell me what to look for while we
analyze no problem i hope
actually it is a problem not what we
agreed ev
judy t-bug's a professional discreet to
a fault
you can trust her why cause you say so
please judy
i'd never expose you to any danger you
know that
okay call t-bug and we'll dive in
hey v what's happening bug listen i got
some useful footage from kenpecki plaza
it's a brain dance kun peki
oh thought as much someone there with
you
unimportant debug please focus need your
help
got no clue what i'm supposed to look
for once i'm in
all right see if i can walk you through
it jacking it to your tech now
you've got to give me access opening
port 1779
secure protocol good i'm going in
should be getting my requests now
got it you ready a millisecond
okay connection confirmed now some quick
tip ice and
we're clear ready to dance fire up judy
all right v eyes open gotta find out
where your noble's keeping the relic
you look like a [ __ ] meat
[ __ ] cameras packed with new tech motion
sensors heat sig activators
iff you skilled enough to kill it all
mucho more than enough just need access
to their subnet
alarm firmware is fresh but saw excited
birds chirping on a bbs
something about lots of seeds falling
through this sieve
let me generate keys i can forge their
six
are you evelyn she i felt a fear
sure got it under control quick too
so
uh
so
[Music]
i said no yeah
have my head for this then you shall
perish
here in a drone ventilation and cooling
servers gotta be fancy doodads in here
need to be controlled
listen in on that conversation v could
be something important
i need a minute to finish the program is
still in the trial phase we cannot take
it to market as is
we shall see soon enough please speak
with your father
he's taken a particular interest in this
project he can certainly
explain the risks my fathers are tired
visually
old graybeard who thinks nothing will
change
and he'll live forever in his tiny
frozen bubble i should not even be
listening to such things
you will listen to this sabroi is an
adult despot utterly removed from
reality
stuck in some fossilized vision of a
world
that no longer exists of a world that
may never have existed
we have not seen eye to eye for the past
20 years
i am quite sure we want now
read the documentation carefully the
relic requires specific storage
conditions
you must provide them you know heard
that
relic docs got to be around here
somewhere look for them
wow champagne's decent
soon
so
but make yourself
comfortable i need a minute to finish
the program
yes we shall see you third enough
is
this old grey beard who thinks
nothing will change and he'll live
forever
such things will listen to this
business
can't be stupid hmm it wasn't long
not even long enough for me to grow
bored is everything
all right you seem tense
edgy
only one
guess on me
oh got any stuff was
pretty fun last time bedroom
nightstand that's again
only one focus oh
any candy left steph was pretty fun last
time
nice got an idea
very nice but come here already just a
sack
looking for the perfect
ever look at me
ah you'll like this
until you
manual details a special tip controlled
container
relic needs to be kept real cool so
chip's got to stay in the freezer
yep could damage it otherwise okay
switch on thermal layer detection in the
editor
should be easier to spot where you are
know who's keeping the chip
mm-hmm
[Music]
i miss this i missed it
an elephant look like a kind of [ __ ]
meat
nope
oh donaghy's looks like mr arasaka had
something to celebrate
really think you'll find the chip in
there no way
tense too low could fluctuate nice try
though
ahead for this then
i need a minute to finish the program is
still in the trial field
market
right grab the heatsink matches the spec
in the docks
your anub's got the case here guaranteed
you got it good work looks like we got
everything we need
quit out of the editor dazzies
we shall see you soon
just a fancy ass fridge he's taking a
particular interest in this
it's in itself
is
get everything you need yep that'll do
thanks judy we got it later t-bug
nice work today see you soon i'll wipe
the cash on your data
you were never here
[Music]
keep it i'll put it on eb's tab
portable device for handling bds i
already uploaded your calibration
settings
not as sophisticated as what we got here
but should do the trick
and it keeps you out of harm's way
clever
speaking of harm's way know what i see
looking at you
walking talking corpses
we needed that recording judy the bd
practically does our job for us
the bd will be the death of us seriously
if arasaka finds out you have it you're
dead
i'm dead judy relax
nobody will ever know evelyn please
no shortcuts you go that route
city you'll always win so be careful
of course i will be besides
we'll talk in a bit
[Music]
hey let's walk
thanks judy really don't worry
i know what i'm doing
[Music]
so
[Music]
so what now v
do this job for me i mean me alone
no splitting the pay out with anyone
else no middlemen
no decks
[Music]
if i agree they'll be held to pay for
sure
i know whatever you decide
stays between us i can offer 50
eddie's enough to do whatever the hell
you like i'll be finished
dex won't forgive a dirt move like this
dex isn't the only fixer in town
but my offer is the only one you'll ever
get
let me think about it
if you need me call i'll send you my
number
okay good luck
now go i need a few words with judy
[Music]
turns out everyone's recording from
kenpecki was worth our time
beautiful t-bug already called said
she's working her magic
we're all set ready to go what now
now we do the job i hired you to do yeah
grabbing that bio
should i come to you
great be there in no time see you mr b